hey guys it is Wednesday my name is Jeff
I'm Dan and you're watching games but
news here's the things that happened in
gaming today it's mostly Star Wars stuff
it's mostly yes sir
[Music]
Marvel heroes the free-to-play Diablo
esque action game from Marvel has been
shut down by Marvel parent company
Disney Marvel Entertainment told
GameSpot we regret to inform our Marvel
heroes fans that we have ended our
relationship with gazillion
entertainment and that the Marvel heroes
games will be shut down we would like to
sincerely thank the players who joined
the Marvel heroes community and will
provide any further updates as they
become available presumably this applies
to both the PC version of the game and
the Omega versions released on ps4 and
Xbox one earlier this year
Kotaku who first reported the news added
that updates from gazillion have been
absent recently while the current and
former employee reported that some
people were told not to come in to work
this week stay tuned for updates on this
one but in the meantime our thoughts go
out to those affected by the shutdown
and let's move on to our theme of today
EA have responded to a number of Star
Wars Battlefront to loot box concerns if
you've been frozen in carbonite and have
only just thought let me catch you up
Star Wars Battlefront 2 has been copping
quite a bit of flak lately about the use
of microtransactions and loot crate's in
multiplayer progression is heavily tied
to the chance based loot system which
means getting the best weapon or
upgrading your favorite class is no
longer just tied to gameplay obviously
this is pretty pudhu so the Intuit
responded in kind which saw a
significantly lower the prices for
certain things such as hero characters
clock white band here we are today EA
CFO Blake your Genson addressed these
updates during a speaking event this
week saying the beauty of games today is
you can constantly tune those games so
things that we heard today will tune in
the game and they'll be different
tomorrow running a live service is all
about constantly watching and listening
to and reacting to the community to try
and develop great gameplay ea wants to
keep players engaged and spending in a
game long after it releases yo Genson
asked for patience as the company finds
acceptable values for things like hero
unlocks adding players should really
understand that we listen to the
community very closely and we will
always be changing the games to make
those games better
it seems games as a service is something
EA is very interested in pursuing as yo
Genson also cited battlefield 4 as a
missed opportunity as it's consistently
in the top 10 played games for the
company and that the game could have
made more money as a live service let us
know what you think of games as a server
below in that comment section also if
you have just been unfrozen what's that
hibernation sickness your site will
return in time sticking with the
Internet's favorite company at the
moment ei Jorgenson is part of that
speaking bit whatever also tastes a new
game coming out that has never before
seen gameplay illness yeah motives are
currently working on a gigantic GTA
style action game under the direction of
X Assassin's Creed producer Jade Raymond
yo Genson said quote action is clearly
the place we're missing the most and the
reason we're building anthem and the new
title that Jade Raymond's team at motive
is building in Montreal that's the
largest sector in gaming it's one that
we haven't spent a lot of time in
because we were so focused on sports and
first-person shooters we feel like
there's a huge opportunity there
regarding the new project at motive he
teased that the game has a lot of new
interesting gameplay that I don't think
anyone's seen ever before and it sounds
like he has faith in the studio citing
the creativity of the 100-plus people
the studio has hired so that's something
to look forward to and those of you that
are keen to hear more on Bioware's new
title anthem we'll be happy to hear EA
CEO Andrew Wilson saw it recently and
said it is looking very exciting that's
everything we have for you today but we
do need to make a correction to our
extra life schedule that we told you
about yesterday we think this is the
final schedule now so now it kicks off
it kicks off at 12 p.m. on Friday in the
US for 36 hours 12 hours in the UK and
then 24 hours right here in Australia
for us rounding it out so please tune in
watch us play games and donate for a
good cause sweet well we will see you
there and tomorrow for a bunch more
gaming news remember anything funny this
today saying funny okay
I'm not funny you'd be something funny
you're funny-looking
god dammit you're right